You'll recall in lesson one, that
according to Jakob Nielsen's research
with only 3 users, upwards of 65% of the
issues in a prototype can be uncovered.
And with only 5 users, upwards of 75% of
the issues can be found in a prototype.
It won't make much sense to do more than
ten research tests on the same prototype
because of the law of
diminishing returns.
The key to effectively
applying Nielsen’s research,
is getting the feedback from three to
five users early on, and continuously
iterating on changes, as you’ve made
incremental changes to your design.
So after you’ve made your
first round of feedback,
make the changes you’ve
received to your designs.
Then, go for
another round of three to five users.
After each round or
iteration you'll find that your
designs will improve efficiently.